l'avenir c'est maintenant disent les
étudiants qui ont développé cette
voiturette de golf autonome car non
seulement les véhicules automatisés sont
une réalité et pourrait être disponible
beaucoup plus tôt qu'on imagine selon
cet expert il estime que si cinq ans il
y en aura beaucoup sur nos routes
pour l'instant il y aura quelqu'un
derrière le volant pour les manoeuvres
d'urgence mais la conduite sera
automatisé le reste du temps dès le 1er
janvier ces voitures pourront circuler
librement sur l'ensemble du réseau
routier ontarien et au rythme où va le
changement est inévitable dit le
ministre du développement économique et
la province a l'intention d'en profiter
le projet pilote d'une durée initiale de
10 ans permettra de développer la
technologie des véhicules dits autonomes
ou connecter des restrictions s'impose
pour utiliser ce type de véhicule il
faudra avoir une formation spéciale
les véhicules seront assurés en cas
d'accrochage l'automobiliste sera
responsable
le gouvernement prévoit que d'ici 2040
75% des véhicules seront automatisées
les avantages prévus sont nombreux ils
vont d'une diminution des accidents à
une augmentation du nombre de voitures
en circulation
non seulement la conduite sera plus
disciplinés mais les véhicules pourront
circuler plus près les uns des autres
il n'empêche que selon cet expert le
canada tire de l'arrière dans le
le mans de cette technologie pour par
hâtivement d'autres juridictions comme
la chine ou le royaume-uni par exemple
la province estime qu'à court et moyen
terme une centaine d'entreprises
pourront bénéficier du développement des
véhicules autonomes
de quoi redonner un second souffle à
l'industrie qui connaît des heures
difficiles en cet entrepreneur dans la
fabrication de pièces d'automobiles ne
cache pas son enthousiasme
il estime que les véhicules autonomes
représenteront pas moins de 5% du marché
dès 2020 ici à lesbos nous radio-canada
waterloo